in the shattering there are those who
could strike fear just by their name
one such is melania blade of mykola and
her clean rot knights who have been
heralded as undefeated during the
shattering
their strength brought out by their lack
of self-preservation
and their faith towards their lord
but there are those who would face them
without fear
and even prove to be a match for their
strength
general radon and his red main soldiers
would face the scarlet rot without fear
however
they would still be defeated when the
scarlet ionia bloomed
but despite the defeat of their lord
their battle would wage on eternally
now one of the most badass factions in
the lands between are the red main
soldiers who serve under general rodon
and in this video i want to showcase
their battle against the scarlet rot and
highlight their lore
they are the faction that holds most of
caled despite its dilapidated state
they serve as the keepers of general
radon's broken mind and conduct the
radon festival in order to honor his
wish to die an honorable death
these soldiers have long since abandoned
any hope of returning home to their life
due to many reasons but first and
foremost is in order to serve their duty
to general radon so much so that even in
death the battle between the clean rot
knights and the red main soldiers still
continue in the catacombs of caled
but to those that still live they have
the duty of holding down the forts
within caled and from those forts they
do what they can to stave off the
scarlet rot
fort gale is one such fort and it's
still being defended by the red main
soldiers
but before we get into the fort the
outskirts of the fort itself has some
pretty interesting stuff it seems that
the red main soldiers are trying to burn
away the scarlet rot and may even likely
be trying to study ways to get rid of it
or at least try to prevent its spread
we see such methods such as setting up
walls infused with fire around kaelin as
well as burning whatever is infected
with the rot
but this doesn't really work too well as
the rot is spreading much much faster
than they can get rid of and ultimately
may just be a hopeless attempt to stave
away the scarlet rot
now going back to fort gale its outer
perimeter is heavily guarded by the
soldiers as well as a knight the fort
itself is also home to a lion guardian
who the soldiers seem to be feeding
infected commoners or likely anything
that is infected in an attempt to get
rid of them as you know there is a true
death in the lands between unless your
soul is hewn into the earth tree so even
burning the corpses would eventually
lead them to rise up as rot infused
shamblers in addition to these
experiments the soldiers stationed here
are also protecting the star scourge
heirloom and a portal that leads to red
main castle
but before we talk about the red main
castle let's talk about the other fort
that they still somewhat hold which is
fort farath well to be honest the fort
itself is already abandoned and is
overtaken by bats but what's interesting
is that spirits would appear here but
these spirits aren't the normal spirits
as well but rather the type of spirits
that also appear in the carion manor
which means it's likely that these
aren't spirits but might be a spell that
protects the treasure deep within the
fort
radon's father seal bratigan sorcil
remember these soldiers and knights were
under the command of general radon who
was part of the carrion royal family
he also learned sorcery in the town of
celia which means some soldiers may have
been versed with sorceries as well so
they may have left a spell here in order
to protect the fort as the soldiers
either succumbed to the scarlet rot or
abandoned the fort or maybe they even
lost to the dragons outside
now alongside the source seal there is
also the half of the medallion of the
grand left of dectus
located here which
oddly enough isn't that protected
now let's talk about the red mains base
of operations which is red main castle
starting with the path to the castle
which has a lot of giant dogs these are
dogs mutated by some form of magic they
also exist in the mountaintop of giants
but the ones here are also mutated by
the scarlet rot
the red main soldiers seem to be hunting
these dogs probably in order to ensure
that they don't get out of kaelin and
threaten the rest of the lands between
and of course spread the scarlet rod
even further
we find the soldiers using the corpses
of the dogs as bait in order to strike
them down in an ambush
afterwards they would burn these dogs
away while also luring more dogs to the
area and like we saw in fort gill and
forced marath they also employ fire
infused walls here but again no luck in
actually staving off the scarlet rot now
approaching the castle will be met with
ranged fire and a whole lot of defenses
but these defenses are taken down during
the radon festival when challengers and
champions are welcome to challenge their
lord
any other time though and red main
castle itself is a fortress that is
quite formidable getting past the bridge
while being pelleted by trebuchet fire
and passing through numerous blockades
will be met with a giant that protects
the front gate and even after you get
past the giant and the closed gate you
are then met with two guardian lions and
if you can't get past the front gate you
have to go around the castle or if the
portal is open you can take the portal
inside
but once we take those down we can look
at the castle itself the castle is
strewn about with weapons and armor and
some of them hanging as decorations
these weapons and armor though are
possibly from those that had challenged
radon before but failed looking at them
closely we find that they are banished
knight equipment alongside trumpets and
probably weapons of former soldiers so i
think it's more likely these are hanged
in honor of those who fought radon to
free him and those who fought alongside
him or they could just be some
decorations they decided to hang because
maybe they have too much weapons
alongside the decor though we see actual
hanged soldiers as well most of them
look like normal rank and file soldiers
so they might have been soldiers who
wanted to abandon their duty and go home
and well that didn't bode too well
within the castle there are several
rooms that can be explored as well in
one of the rooms there are commoners
seemingly gathered around like cattle
these may be the caretakers of the
castle or refugees from around caled who
sought refuge within red main castle
however we also find a lot of their
corpses here indicating that they might
not be here to be safe but might be kept
here as they might be infected with a
scarlet rot and if it progresses further
may have to be killed and burned
further inwards the fort we find more
defenses in the form of flamethrowers
and an abductor virgin
now this isn't really out of place as i
mentioned multiple times radon is part
of the carrion royal family so he would
certainly have access to such machinery
further beyond and above the castle
walls we would find the majority of the
inhabitants of the castle who are the
red main soldiers
what's interesting is that these
soldiers may be inflicted with the
scarlet rot as when you kill them they
would drop smoldering butterflies now
nascent butterflies are quite rare in
the lands between but ionian butterflies
are present wherever there is scarlet
rot so they may have been infected by
the rot and like the lands in order to
save it away they burn themselves this
isn't really something new as the
incantation flame cleanse me also has a
similar effect when clearing afflictions
in that it leaves burns behind however
as we know lore wise the scarlet rod
isn't so easily removed this may have
also been one of the reasons why the red
main soldiers can no longer leave kaelin
as they might spread the rot elsewhere
the knights themselves even burned away
their crest in order to indicate the
resolve that they would no longer return
home
now let's talk about the red main
soldiers themselves they are well
reputed to be masterful warriors so much
so that they were popularly known to
have no weakness
as such even the average soldiers of
radhan are more skilled than the average
soldier but the knights that serve under
radon himself are far more skilled one
such knight is oga who also studied
gravity magic alongside radon and is
able to use a weaker version of radon's
skill with the bow and gravity albeit
only once
these knights wear a red plume on their
helmets as a symbol of radon's pedigree
and divinity as radigan's son and carry
shields to proudly state their loyalty
to the general all the knights of radon
do this but one
the knight gerund he served as a guest
commander to general radon jiren was a
nomad before but spent time with the
carrion royals my guess is that he was
hired by the carrion royals in order to
hunt down selen but during his time
under their employ he befriended the
carrion royals but most importantly
general radon they became such close
friends that they swore an oath of
honorable death to one another one which
jiren is still attempting to accomplish
to this day his time with the carrion
royals made him quite close with them as
he is well acquainted with eg and he
calls ronnie princess ronnie he is also
aware that general radon is holding
ronnie's fate
well
i haven't heard that name in an age
then you must serve princess ronnie
the next time you speak to eg
tell him this
the festival of radon will surely set
ronnie's fate back into motion
bye-bye is that old fool still hammering
out weapons
his enormous frame cramped in that
little place
bit of a haughty sword
strange fella when i knew him
and funny thing
his swords were all blunt as stone
but not one of them decayed when faced
with a scarlet rot
and in order to free that fate he must
complete his oath and deliver an
honorable death to general radon which
is why he created the radon festival
and during the radon festival it would
be the tarnished who would be lord and a
company of great warriors who would
finally put the great general to sleep
freeing jiren from his oath and with
general radon felt jiren and the red
main soldiers are finally free from
their service now jaren would resume his
hunt for sellen and with the scarlet rod
still affecting caled it doesn't feel
like the red main soldiers would abandon
their duty to protect the lands between
but that's all for this video about the
red main soldiers of radon do you think
the red main knights will ever be free
from the eternal battle or do you think
they'll be stuck in caled forever
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and if you like this
video please don't forget to hit the
like button it really really helps out
the channel and if you're new to the
channel and like the content be sure to
hit that subscribe button thank you so
much for watching